on bad friends you said that there's
this
new guy who came into our lives
right and you painted him out to be
somebody
that like it's just new and random and
then andrew suggested it it was someone
that i dated
and i just want to set the record
straight yeah i love your little [ __ ]
fabrications that you do
for bad friends but i've known
my one of my best friends say his name
corey
high school since high school love him
he also was
our roommate for a decade okay and
also i don't want to get a fight he's
also known juliana he's also he's been
to the philippines multiple times and
he's known juliana since she was four
years old okay when juliana says
that she likes him right
as much as she likes me that's where i
draw the [ __ ] line
okay go ahead uh also she said she likes
him
because he's funny oh no see
which he is he's hilarious he's
literally like organically just one of
the funniest people i've ever been okay
to you what is the context to you okay
back up the contacts
let me just say thank you we roll the
clip on bad friends
yeah okay right so i want to say all
right he's
hilarious to you right
okay it's like do you know how many
times
as as a comic i've been at clubs and
i've met people go
oh man i have a friend named william
william cho
he's hilarious just like you he cracks
everyone up at work
yeah he's not funny though but see
that's not that corey
doesn't try ever to be funny he just is
himself he's the nicest guy in the world
here's where
um a non-negotiable for me corey is not
a friend he's my brother i've i've been
through life with him since i was
a teenager and so you can't go ahead
and have these competitive feelings
with about him because he's a
non-negotiable i'm keeping him in my
life forever
and i and he's not a new person i also i
am welcoming
welcoming him into my life as well okay
that's what i'm saying i'm just bringing
it up for comedy purposes
but the fabrications are there's no
fabrications is there one fabrication
yeah give me a fabrication
exactly you said
you said that i've only known him for
two months
okay it's again a comedy fabrication
okay but that is a fabrication just just
all comedies of fabrication
everything about you is a fabrication
all stories are fabrications
yeah everything that i say on this mic
right
goes through a channel of fabrication
okay yeah channel five yeah
right it goes through a thing in my head
you're a fabric softener
exactly basically right but my point is
is i have nothing against
your best friend and your brother corey
who's the robin williams of long beach
or whatever you want to
say oh right is that what they say long
beach wherever he's from
right and what is how i like pasadena i
love the guy yeah right
i just find it offensive that
jules likes him as much as me that's all
you want to be the number one in her
life it's not that it's just that it's
um
are there other people that you would be
okay with that she liked ahead of you
what's and he will not have it
oh okay that's only because
of the tweet thing got it yeah okay what
sweet thing
when i said when john malini went to
rehab yeah right and everyone made a big
deal out of it yeah
and i said i tweeted i tweeted it's good
i've been to four rehabs and no one
gives us gives a [ __ ]
i was gonna tweet right so that was the
last real comedy tweet that i did yeah
right
and i remember i got off a [ __ ]
twitter for six months
that was